Okay.
Good morning.
We're going to make the transition today to talking about Marxism,
the second of the three enlightenment traditions that we're going to consider in
the first part of this course.
And I should warn you at the outset that I have something of a heterodox view of
marks.
Um,
hang on.
This seems like it's a little loud.
Okay.
I have something of a heterodox view of marks in that if you went and read for
instance,
is a book by a man called Graham Dunkin called marks and male.
Um,
he basically,
his storyline is that marks and mill operate with fundamentally opposed
paradigms.
They have paradigms meaning foundational assumptions so that marks and mail make
completely,
uh,
incommensurable an incompatible assumptions about how the world works and the
political theory that can flow from those assumptions.
And so to some extent they are,
uh,
he thinks on all the big questions speaking past one another that,
that basically,
um,
uh,
you can adjudicate if you like,
um,
the disagreements between them in part because he thinks they speaking from
fundamentally opposed paradigms,
I think that you couldn't be more wrong headed.
Marks and mail are creatures of the enlightenment both.
And therefore we will find in a,
we in examining marks that just like all of the Utilitarians we've already
considered so far,
um,
that both committed to basing politics on a scientific theory of Human
Association and two,
in committing themselves to individual freedom as the basic and most important
principle of politics.
If,
if you guys want to talk you can you do it somewhere else cause it's really
distracting.
Okay.
Thanks.
Um,
now,
so let's,
before we get into the details of Marx's own argument,
um,
let's say a few general things about marks as an enlightenment thinker.
And if we think about the enlightenment think is,
first of all,
as committed to science,
there's no question that Marx was committed to a scientific theory of politics.
If you read his,
his attack on prude horn and the Utopian socialists for example,
it was all about attacking them for,
um,
being unscientific in there thinking it was all about a rejecting sentimentalism
or wishful thinking,
uh,
and trying to understand what was feasible and what was not feasible in
politics.
So Mark's has a scientific conception.
Of course it is.
It's,
it's not,
doesn't come within a country mile of the scientific conceptions.
We saw both among early enlightenment theorists like bent them or mature
enlightenment theorists like male,
uh,
rather,
Mark's is committed to something called the materialist conception of history.
And the materialist conception of history is the idea that,
um,
I,
to use another one of his,
his,
uh,
rear,
the impenetrable raises,
he's considered committed to the idea of dialectical materialism.
And you might say,
well,
what is dialectical materialism?
This comes from the idea first articulated by a German philosopher called Hagle
that history moves into kind of zigzag,
fits and starts,
um,
the dialectical ideas that um,
some change gets made,
some innovation gets made.
This though breeds a kind of undertow,
a resistance against the change,
the first change.
And then you get,
uh,
as a result of the initial change,
the undertow,
the kind of pushback,
but which isn't the same as a push back to where you started from.
You get a new starting point.
So Hey,
goes famous terms with thesis,
antithesis and synthesis.
The thesis is a a change.
So you get say the transition from um,
serfdom to a market based society,
then you get resistance to that market space.
Society,
you would get a new working class comes into being let's say,
and then that working class becomes the agent of a new change that will produce
its own antithesis in new sentences.
So history goes like this if you like,
it doesn't go in a straight line but it goes in a direction,
it goes forward in some sense.
And Hegel's idea had been that the,
that history eventually reaches an ending point and he thought the ending point
was the Prussian state of his day.
He thought all of history was the evolving toward this,
this supreme highest point of the Prussian state of his day.
And it was guided by the working out of ideas in history.
Mark's turns this on his head,
on it's head,
I should say,
not on his hand marks,
turns it on its head saying,
well,
um,
yes,
history goes in this kind of zigzag direction of thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis,
thesis,
and then the synthesis becomes the new thesis.
And so on.
And yes,
it has an end point,
which is he thinks as a communist utopia,
but it's not driven by ideas.
It's not driven by ideas at all.
Instead,
it's driven by material interests.
So that's why mark has view is sometimes called,
as I said,
dialectical materialism.
It's driven by material interests.
Or as Bill Clinton would have put it in the end,
it is the Bill Clinton did put it in the 1992 campaign.
It's the economy stupid.
That's the basic idea behind materialism,
that ideas,
um,
culture,
beliefs,
all of that stuff is what Mark's referred to as super structure.
It's not really important.
What is important is the economic base.
So that economic interests drive everything over time.
And if you want to understand how a political system works,
you better understand the economic system.
So in this sense,
it's a very different view than Bentham or mail or any of these folks because
they really working in the realm of ideas,
right?
They're not,
Hey k aliens to be sure.
But they think that this idea of shaping society and in terms of their
utilitarian calculus can be used in order to reorganize things for marks.
That would be an absurd,
completely absurd agenda.
You have to start with the economy.
It's the economy stupid.
You have to understand what the power forces are in the economy and what the
tensions and possibilities are within the economy before you can understand
anything else about politics.
And in that respect,
I think one thing you should really get stripe right away is,
um,
just what Marx thought about capitalism.
How many people here thought marches against capitalism?
March was against capitalism.
Almost nobody march wasn't against capitalism.
How many think he was fighting against capitalism?
Okay,
why,
why do you think he wasn't against capitalism?
It did just let's get the mic.
I mean,
he wasn't against capitalism because capitalism was a necessary step in,
uh,
in getting to socialism.
So
you're exactly right.
So what Marx thought about capitalism wise,
and we're going to understand the reasons for this in detail in the next couple
of lectures that for a certain phase of history,
it essential.
It was the most,
he thought capitalism was the most innovative dynamic,
um,
productive mode of production that had ever been dreamed up.
And there was no way you could even think about as socialist or communist
society developing unless you had capitalism first and in this and smarts would
have had absolutely no sympathy for the Russian revolution,
which was done in a peasant society,
um,
or Ma or the Chinese Communist system.
Uh,
either,
um,
he would have said that they were completely premature because in the end it's
going to be capitalism which is necessary to generate the wherewithal to make
socialism possible.
So he wouldn't have had any sympathy with the Leninist or stolen as projects,
which we'll talk about later so that he is not against capitalism.
What he thinks about capitalism is that it's sawing off the branch.
It's sitting on over time.
That is to say there are basic contradictions within the way capitalism works
and indeed the very things that make capitalism the most productive mode of
production ever to existed in human history at one point,
those very,
very same dynamics ultimately will undermine it.
Um,
so he,
so in that sense don't think of a medicine as simply against capitalism.
He rather wants to understand the dynamics process that brings capitalism into
being,
leads it to maturity and eventually leads it to self destruct and that that is
the story that he's going to tell us.
So he has a scientific theory.
It's a materialist theory.
Um,
and it's,
it's based on this metaphor of the base and super structure.
Um,
people have come up with other metaphors,
skeleton and flash and so on,
but the,
that you can play with them.
But the,
the,
the core idea is that it's,
it's the material relations that shape everything else.
More controversially though from people might say is to say,
well,
Marxists really a believer in individual rights and freedoms.
Most people say what marks a believer in individual rights.
And Mark's thinking that freedom is important.
Most people say no marks is an egalitarian.
Mark's is all about equality.
And one of the things I'm going to suggest to you in my exposition of marks is
that that is,
um,
basically wrongheaded you'll see that when we come to talk about his idea of a
communist utopia,
one of his bumper stickers for that is the notion that the claim that the free
development of each is a condition for the free development of wall.
The free development of each is the condition for the free development of all.
So he's an egalitarian in the sense that yes,
he wants everybody to have freedom and he thinks that that is denied to many
people in,
in most forms of social organization.
But freedom is the most important value nonetheless.
And he wants to assured for everybody.
Um,
and related to that,
you'll see when we come to talk about,
uh,
nay on Wednesday or next Monday,
the labor theory of value,
that the basic thing that drives marks is a theory of alienation from our true
selves.
We can't be free unless we're at one without true selves.
And every system of social organization before communism in his view,
makes it impossible for us to be at one without true selves.
We are alienated from our true natures as productive creatures by the way in
which society is organized.
And that's the basic problem.
So we had denied our capacity for free action according to Marx,
and he thinks we can never realize it until we reach this communist utopia.
So the,
the,
the takeaway point is going to be that Marx is an enlightenment theorist.
Par exsalonce passe.
People like Duncan.
Um,
it's simply not correct to see him as doing something fundamentally different
than the real enlightenment thinkers such as mill and Bentham.
Mark's isn't enlightenment thinker.
And when you want to see radical critiques of the enlightenment,
you have to go to people like Burke and other,
uh,
anti enlightenment thinkers who were going to be getting two after spring break.
The second point related to Mark's and individual rights and freedoms is,
is you're going to see that we're going to go back to our discussion of lock and
you're going to discover that marks is a true Lockian believer and the
workmanship ideal,
not in his theory of science,
but in his theory of rights and entitlements,
Marxists going to embrace a kind of doctrine of self ownership.
And the idea that we make,
we own what we make as the basis for his theory of exploitation because his
theory of exploitation is gonna turn on the claim that people are in fact denied
the fruits of their own labor because of the way that the system is set up.
Well,
you could say,
so why,
why should we care that people are designed,
did deny the fruits of their own labor unless they're entitled to the fruits of
their own neighbor.
And indeed that is Marx's view.
So you will see that in it may be I was once accused of,
uh,
belittling marks by calling him a,
a minor posts.
Lockian um,
but with respect to the labor theory of value and you will see that the main
conceptual ideas that that go into it are straight out of lock second treaties
and it's straight out of the workmanship ideal.
What Marx is going to try and do when we get to the labor theory of value is
give a secular version of the workmanship ideal.
And indeed developing a viable secular version of the workmanship ideal is,
is a project with as at least as long a history as the history of utilitarianism
and at least as fraught with difficulties as the history of utilitarianism.
And we will see when we get to roles even more radical attempts than Mark's,
uh,
to develop secular version of the labor theory of value in the workmanship model
and the difficulties it runs into.
But so Mark's we'll see is the first in a long line of people who try to
secularize the workmanship ideal by creating this labor theory of value,
um,
that's going to have,
are a rather checkered future,
um,
as we explore it into the 20th century.
And so that's where we had ink.
We're going to explore marks as an enlightenment thinker with,
uh,
by means of three lectures.
And the first one is going to deal with the marks and the challenge of classical
political economy.
Now,
why do I say that?
Because really there are two Marx's,
if you,
if you were taking a course in the history of ideas that had more than three
lectures on marks,
what you would discover is a lot of attention to his German roots.
I've already mentioned that he was a disciple and critic of Hagle,
the German idealist,
philosopher,
um,
but much of his writing until the mid 19th century was inspired by his critique
of,
Hey,
goes other followers and disciples and we're pretty much not going to deal with
that.
We're not going to deal with the German marks when not by and large going to
deal with the young Marx Rather.
What,
what happened to him was he Marx thought you may or may not know this,
but in 1830s,
there were revolutions across Europe.
Kings and Queens were,
uh,
kicked out of office and democracy came to power and what marks and many of
those around him thought this is the beginning of the end of capitalism.
By 1830 to 1833,
all of those democratic revolutions had failed and the Monica is,
had been restored across Europe.
But then
in 1848,
there was another whole series of revolutions across Europe.
And once again,
Marx thought maybe this is the beginning of the end and had great faith and
optimism that that was going to be the case.
But by 1851,
uh,
those revolutions had all again failed and the mechanics were back in power and
marks after that became steadily more dejected and steadily more skeptical over
his remaining years that in fact he was going to see a communist revolution in
his lifetime and rather he invested in,
um,
the project of trying to understand capitalism in a much more systematic way
than he had done in his youth.
He was also,
he was kicked out of Germany.
He couldn't go to France and he wound up in London and he lived the second,
the last decades of his life in London.
Um,
and in fact died and was buried there.
If you,
if you ever in London,
you can go up to um,
Highgate cemetery on the northern line.
It's a very interesting cemetery.
They all kinds of interesting people.
They had George Elliot is there.
Anyway,
there is Karl Marx in Highgate cemetery.
It's all overgrown and very.
Anyway,
he spent his last decades working in the basement of the British Museum and
that's where he composed his magnum opus is three volume work,
Dusk Kapa Tolle.
It was actually envisaged as a 12 volume work and the only volume that was
published in his lifetime was actually volume one.
Uh,
the second and third volumes were put together by his friend and collaborator,
Frederick Engels.
Um,
and unfortunately for us the volumes about politics,
uh,
whenever written.
So you have to some extent to put together his views of his mature views about
politics from a scrap see road here and there and some of the,
um,
short pieces about politics that do appear in the,
in the Oli volumes.
Um,
so we're going to mostly focus on the mature marks.
We're mostly gonna focus on Mark's as he set himself the task of understanding
the dynamics of capitalism after he had pretty much given up on his useful
youthful enthusiasm for the,
for the quick transformation the world and to socialist and communist societies,
which he basically started to shed a after 1848 with a brief revival of interest
in 18,
17.
Jay Given events in France.
Uh,
but basically it was a trajectory and from opt youthful optimism into,
um,
mature pessimism,
at least from his point of view.
Okay.
So what he did was he said,
Tim South,
well,
what is it that people are involved in who engage in the Syria systematic
analysis of capitalism.
And here Mark's is,
we,
we tend to present marks as an unorthodox or radical thinker,
but in fact,
he was a very conventional thank for his day.
That is to say Marx was a follower of Adam Smith and David Ricardo.
Um,
and,
and he saw the himself largely as tackling and refining the theorists,
the theories that they developed.
And what I want to do with,
uh,
the rest of our time this morning is say something about the project of
classical political economy that Mark's inherited and contributed to and why he
thought getting the,
the basic problems that the classical political economists we're trying to solve
solved would enable us to understand what the real conditions were that would
eventually lead to the collapse of capitalism.
The most important feature of capitalism as far as Adam Smith was concerned and
the wealth of nations and his followers after him
was the division of Labor.
Okay.
The division of Labor is really important because it has two features.
One,
as far as marks will be concerned,
it begins the process of alienating us from ourselves.
Why does it do that?
It does that because we start instead of producing things that we then consume,
okay.
We start producing things in a,
in a situation where we divide up tasks,
um,
okay.
And that makes it impossible for us to live rounded lives.
That's ultimately where it's going to go.
But second and much,
much more important from the point of view of economics is that the division of
Labor is the engine of productivity.
The more you,
you're more,
you engage in the division of labor,
the more productive you make people.
And Smith has this wonderful,
this,
this wonderful example right near the beginning of the wealth of nations where
he talks about a pin factory.
Smith has been going around England,
China understand where,
where the dynamism and the English economy is and he says he's,
he gives us description of a pin factory.
He says,
one man draws out the wire,
another straight said a third cuts it a fourth points it at fifth grinds at the
top for receiving the head to make the head requires two or three distinct
operations.
To put it on it's on is a big,
to put it on is a peculiar business.
To widen the pins is another,
it is even a trade by itself to put them into the paper.
And the important business of making a pin is in this man,
a divided into about 18 distinct operations.
As a result of that division of labor,
though a Smith calculated that 10 workers could make 48,000 pins a day.
But if they had all worked separately and independently,
all they could have produced was a few dozen.
So that,
that basic insight of smiths,
that it's the division of Labor that is the engine of capitalists productivity
set,
set terms for his own,
for Adam Smith's analysis of markets and the wealth of nations for Ricardo's
refined my,
uh,
and for locks ref for hop.
I'm sorry,
mark.
So should be fine,
man.
Of both of their arguments,
uh,
in das capital.
So what were,
okay,
what was the project of classical political economy?
What was it that marks was stepping into and trying to contribute to?
Well,
one way of describing it
as I have it here is it was the search for theories of natural and market.
Got Theories that twice,
sorry search.
But there is a natural and market wages,
prices,
rents and profits.
They want it to understand what determines wages,
prices,
rents and profits.
But they thought you had to have a theory of natural wages,
prices,
rents and profits and market wages,
rents and profits.
Now let's focus on prices because the,
the,
the way the other three are treated is basically an by an allergy to the
analysis of prices.
A modern neoclassical economist would say there is no natural price of anything.
Ahmad neoclassical economists would say,
what determines prices is supply and demand in the market.
There is nothing else to say about prices.
And they gave up the notion that this,
any natural theory of wages,
prices,
rents and profits to be found.
So the big difference between the classical theorists and the modern theorists
is this idea that there's a theory of natural prices.
Now why would they think there's a theory of natural prices?
The reason they thought there was a theory of natural prices was they weren't
arguing with people like the physio Kratz and the trade theorists about where
value comes from.
What is the source of value?
The physiocrats and France said the source of value is the land.
Yeah.
That somehow it gets transferred to the products.
Where's the,
the trade theorist who had been impressed that countries like Holland heads,
which had so little land,
but it comes a Rick said no value comes from trade.
So they were all sort of saying,
you know,
yeah.
Where is the [inaudible]?
What is the source of value?
And the English theorist following,
um,
lock petty.
So William Petty,
John Locke Hobbes all believed that the way you find value is to go into labor.
That work.
Workmanship is the source of value.
So all let it class.
A couple medical economist,
Smith,
Ricardo and Marx believed in the Labor theory of value and they count to pose
that to theories based on trade or the physiocrats theories,
uh,
that were popular in France.
Um,
as I've said,
so that's one reason,
but another is that they didn't,
it's not the case that they were ignorant of the laws of supply and demand.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and we'll see how Mark's handles them.
Uh,
on Wednesday.
It's not the case that they're ignorant of the laws of supply and demand,
but they thought it couldn't possibly tell you the whole story.
So,
okay.
If you can think about it this way,
suppose there is a,
a dearth in the supply off coffee marks,
the price will go up.
Okay.
They didn't disagree with that.
Right.
And if they're too many coffee mugs,
coffee mugs and anybody who wants the price will go down and I may,
maybe somebody will realize you can drill holes in the bottom there and then use
them to grow plants in a and then maybe their price would go up a bit because
they'll be more,
but they thought that supply and demand fluctuate.
Um,
with what it is that people actually want.
They didn't have any problem with that notion,
but still in all they thought there must be something that will tell you what
the price is when supply and demand are in equilibrium in other,
in other way you can think about it is supply and demand go up and down,
but they go up and down around some point.
I wonder what tells you what that point is.
Yeah,
fit.
That's why the Labor theory about he was supposed to do,
that's the natural price.
I think a modern economist might call it the long run equilibrium price.
That's one way in which,
if you wanted to find an analogy in modern economic thinking to this classical
idea of a natural price,
it's the long run equilibrium price.
It's the price of a commodity when supply and demand rns equilibrium.
So the Labor theory of value was the theory of that.
It was going to chatty you walk the long run equilibrium price of a commodity
would be okay.
And all of the classical political economists with trying to have a theory off
that.
Uh,
so when you read natural prices,
um,
that's what you should think.
You know,
what,
what is,
they're trying to understand what not marginal changes as,
as in the sense of a parade.
Oh,
diagram.
Um,
but the long run changes given the marginal fluctuations around some point.
The question is what is that point?
Uh,
and that's what the Labor theory of value was designed to give you.
It was a theory and that sense of natural prices,
not a theory of market prices.
They thought you have to have both supply and demand gave you the market price.
The Labor theory of value gave you an actual price.
The second big problem that frame the project of classical political economy was
that they all believed as they looked around them,
that there was a declining tendency in the rate of profit.
This was taken as an as,
as a given.
Okay.
It's a given widely accepted empirical fact.
And so if it was the case that there's the right of profit,
tends to decline over time,
can be offset by virus things and so on,
which we will talk about.
But if it's the case that the rate of profit in capitalist economies declines
over time,
your theory isn't going to be worth a damn unless you can explain why.
So one of the tests,
if you'd like,
have a good theory as far as Smith was concerned,
is smart,
far as Ricardo was concerned and as far as was concerned was it had to explain
the declining tendency in the rate of profit.
And Ms. Smith had an account,
uh,
Ricardo had an account and Mark's had an account.
They all different somewhat.
They will all have overlapped in some ways.
We'll see.
Part of the reason they think all three of them thought you would have to have
imperialism was you,
you,
you needed new markets to offset this problem of the declining tendency and the
rate of profit at home.
But that was only going to be a temporary stop gap,
uh,
or solution.
But in any event,
your theory wasn't going to be worth anything unless it pet.
Explain why pri prices are what they are.
Theory of long run equilibrium prices and second,
unless
it gave
have a credible account of why profits fall in capitalist systems over time.
Now a third conceptual point to make that you need in order to understand the
project of classical political economy as Marx understood it is actually related
to the first point,
but I'm just singling it out because people sometimes get confused about it.
It's a distinction that Marx makes between use value and exchange value.
Sometimes you will see Marx uses the word value with a big V.
Okay?
You should just read that as exchange value.
Okay,
so value with a big V is value is exchanged value.
So what is the difference between use value and exchange value?
Well,
from Mark's use value is you tell him
that's all it is.
Use value is simply usefulness
and he has a kind of binary theory of use value.
Either things have used value or they don't.
So coffee cops have a use value can drink out of them.
If somebody drilled holes in the bottom of them,
they would have no use value.
Um,
tell somebody came along and said,
well,
we could use them to grow plants,
then they would have use value.
So thanks.
Either have use value or they don't.
And I'll come back to that in a minute.
Um,
and that's going to affect the supply and demand,
but it's not going to explain the price.
It's not going to explain the long run equilibrium price.
That is the exchange of value.
And that is what we learn about from the labor theory of value as far as Marx
was concerned.
So it's the labor theory of value explains the price and is not to be confused
with the use value or utility of an object.
Again,
one important difference and maybe the most important difference between
classical political economy and neoclassical political economy is we will see
later the neoclassical people shed the labor theory of value.
And so there is no exchange value independent of utility.
Uh,
but we'll get to that.
That's getting ahead of ourselves as far as you're concerned with.
Then when you concerned with the classical formulations and in the 19th century
exchange value or price or value with the big V is determined by the Labor
theory of value and use value is usefulness.
And that brings me to Marxists.
Definition of a commodity.
A commodity has a very special meaningful marks.
It's something that is produced or exchange.
So if you produce,
if you grow,
if you grow and you grow,
you plant an apple tree in your grow apples in order to eat them,
you producing for consumption,
those apples are not commodities.
But if you plant an apple tree and grow apples and sell them,
then those apples are commodities like you put something is a commodity if it's
produced for exchange.
And that's very important because once you have a division of labor,
you have more and more commodity production.
And you might recall in my very first lecture I said that one of the things mark
shares in common with Bentham is he somebody who pushes the idea he has to the
absolute extreme.
And then even beyond that,
so what,
what are we going to see happen with marks?
And commodification is exactly analogous to bent them and utility that Bentham
says,
how would the world look if utility maximization was the only game in town,
if there was nothing else at all?
And so he's theory runs with marks.
It's how would the world look if commodification was the only game in town?
Everything in a capitalist system becomes a commodity.
Even the worker himself,
even the worker himself.
And when we start to understand the dynamics of capitalist production,
we'll see that the analysis of the value of a worker is no different than the
analysis of the value of the pen that the workup producers in Adam Smith's
factory.
So he takes this idea of commodification and pushes that to the health.
So I think if you think about those four features of the project,
of classical political economy,
it gives you a sense of what was Mark's in marks his head as he set off to try
and understand the dynamics of capitalist systems.
And what he did was he said,
well,
we have to understand first of all how capitalist systems look to the
participants
because the way in which they look to the participants is not the same as the
way in which they really work.
So there's a basic distinction if you like,
between parents and reality.
The way in which people think market systems work isn't the way in which they
actually work.
So it's a little like Bentham saying,
you might,
you know,
you might think you're not motivated by utility and all the rest of it,
but in fact you are in the rack case.
We get it right.
Not The rat case is that we get it wrong.
And this sense marks like Bentham is an objectivist.
He thinks he's describing scientifically the laws of motion of capitalist
systems.
Um,
regardless of whether the participants in those systems understand these laws of
motion.
And for the most part,
they don't.
Indeed,
he will.
He's gonna claim ultimately that a socialist revolution differs from all others
because for the first time in history,
people understand the social relations that they're part of and soak
unselfconsciously transform them.
Um,
and create a n I'm alienated social order,
but so he,
so he eats at the beginning of volume one of capital.
He's basically saying,
how does it look to the participants?
Well,
if you have a division of labor,
you look around,
what do you actually see?
You see people producing commodities.
Yeah.
They change those commodities for money and then they use that money to buy
other commodities which they consume.
So you have these cycles of exchange,
commodity money,
commodity.
Okay.
Right.
So the person working,
you know,
producing apple,
growing apples,
sells the from money and then uses the money to buy milk and eggs and so on.
And the simplest case,
right?
So that if you know,
if someone landed from Mars in the middle of a capitalist economy,
that's what they would see all of these people producing things,
exchanging those things from money and buying other things which they then
consume.
Right?
That was the idea.
But then
if you look a little bit more carefully,
you'll see that actually some people are doing something entirely different.
Most people are producing commodities,
exchange in the commodities for money and then using the money to buy other
commodities that they consume.
But mark says some people are doing something different that taking some money,
buy a commodity in this case that the labor of the worker for a certain time and
then selling what gets produced for more money so then are interested in
consumption.
It doesn't seem at least at first sight.
And indeed if you look even more closely,
you'll see that when they do that
the money they end up with is more than the money they started with.
M prime is bigger than m
and the question,
the organizing question of Das copic tall and that was the question that
preoccupied Adam Smith and David Ricardo before marks and as I said in this
sense he was a completely orthodox classical theorists is radicalism comes in
later.
The question is where does prime come from?
What makes profit possible?
You're not going to explain why profits decline after all.
If you can't understand where profits come from,
what is the origin of
profit?
That's the basic problem.
The transformation of money into capital has to be developed on the basis of the
eminent laws of the exchange of commodities in such a way that the starting
point is the exchange of equivalence,
the money [inaudible] who is as yet only the capitalist in larval form must by
his commodities at that value,
sell them at their value and yet at the end of the process withdraw more value
from circulation.
Then he threw into it at the beginning.
It's emergence as a butterfly mass and yet must not take place in the cert fear
of circulation.
These are the conditions of the problem.
Very famous passage at the beginning of capital telling us that if you want to
understand why the capitalist winds up with more,
you have to understand the source of value because it's not about,
it's not,
there's no cheating equivalence exchange for equivalence in every one of those
cycles.
It's not that somehow the worker is tricked into selling his labor power for
less than it's worth.
On the contrary,
he's paid exactly what it's worth.
So once you can understand that puzzle,
okay,
of how when equivalents exchange for equivalence,
new value is still nonetheless created,
then you understand the secret to where profit comes from.
You know the source of value,
and you can begin the process of understanding that dynamic productiveness of
capitalism and why it will eventually start to fall apart.
And we will dig into those subjects on Wednesday.